it's crazy I don't think trolls know
that anybody is just one click away from
knowing from them being completely
exposed it's the same thing on Twitter
or really anything right you see someone
say something crazy you just click on
their profile and it's all crazy all
crazy all the time to everybody yeah
they're complaining about everything
after Roseann was on I got a bunch of
people that tweeted at me with these
wacky conspiracies like wacky
mind-control conspiracies and what would
it seem to me to be not a professional
but if I had a guess a wave of mentally
ill people yeah
we're contacting me and I was reading
some like Jesus Christ how many [ __ ]
people are out there that believe like
the most nuttiest CIA based mind-control
experiments and NSA you know tapping
into everything in your home and
listening to your conversations by
listening to the vibrations off of your
window panes like here's what people
don't know who's got time for that
here's the thing do you really think
there's enough people in the world to be
paying attention to all the people in
the world does that make any sense to
you it shouldn't there's no way
everybody's watching everybody right
there's not enough people see like if
you do something like say Tony
Hinchcliffe runs for president oh
they're gonna [ __ ] watch you for sure
they're gonna find out why is Tony hench
good friend of a president who's backing
is it George Soros who's looking out for
Tony Hinchcliffe you know who's trying
to who's fourth yeah they'll check you
out but the average person is like
remember that Mel Gibson movie
conspiracy theory remember that he
played a mentally ill person who fell in
love with Julia Roberts he was like a
hot mentally ill person and he just
believed everything was a conspiracy
theory he said I watched it the other
day like out of nowhere it was on TV and
I still mean watch this for a little bit
I was like wow a [ __ ] whackies this
movie people that have schizophrenia
don't realize that they're schizophrenic
exact people with bipolar notice there
and they might be aware that there
in episode people OCD their OCD a dee da
dee dee schizophrenia it's game set
match you start hearing the voices
become a normal thing like you think
everybody can hear them and you're not
really acknowledging them because they
become so natural the schizophrenic
person can be in a psych ward and say to
their doctor why am I here and that's a
breakthrough